all right veronica yes veronica where'd
you grow up where are you from virginia
i'm originally from uh whittier norwalk
area
um which is close to santa fe springs
downy bellflower out in that way
and tell me about your family growing up
with your parents yeah i lived with my
parents um
and i also lived with my grandmother
and i lived with my godparents
so your
parents were
your main caregivers or not yeah yeah my
whole life yeah your whole family lived
absolutely how old are you i'm 31 31
do you have kids yes i have one
where where's she's with her father okay
yeah
so you ended up
in jail which is where i found you yeah
you can't you just got out of jail today
absolutely yeah how did you end up in
jail um i ended up in jail because i did
they charged me with a 211 robbery i
went to
a cvs and i decided to steal and they
asked me for the merchandise back and i
refused
and so what happened was they came and
approached me the officers i was waiting
at the bus stop to go on the bus the
officers came and approached me asking
if i'd stolen anything that i needed to
return back to them and i refused to
admit that i had
stolen stuff and that i had anything and
they searched me and they found that i
had stolen items and they uh charged me
with a 211 robbery so they sent me
upstate
how long have you been in jail um i've
been in jail now on a probation
violation for four months i mean i'm so
sorry for a month and four days
you've been in jail before um i've been
in jail before uh yes absolutely
so tell me
the the life you're leading before you
got into jail before you started going
to jail um i was just living a
traditional life like you know like i
lived you know just
um go to work you know i was working at
a retailer mervins was one of them and
that was when i was 18 and then um
that's it
and drugs are a part of your life
absolutely
which ones um dope i call it dope they
call it meth
yeah i call it dope
nicer word i think
but i got math you know i lost findings
on math it's just a little harsh for me
but that's it yeah you're smoking
crystalline yeah crystal mathematical
christmas
um i've been doing it at when i was 13 i
started 13.
but i didn't go consistently through i
had put it down for a while
have you been homeless lately yes
absolutely
i lost my job and ever since then
because i had after the mervyn's i'd
worked in a just receptionist and as a
receptionist i uh
i lost my job and i didn't return to
doing receptionist so i split up with my
daughter's dad and i had to get out of
my apartment and
so i've been outside and she's been with
him since then
have you been treated for
mental absolutely
show us what you get okay get the house
is it from the jail yes from the gel
when they released you they gave you all
this yes
i get um
i get a step coat
i get um
rispidol i get lexapro
i get trosodone
and i get risk at all
and then this is just the increase of
the depakote
so this is for schizophrenia
schizophrenia bipolar depression
wow
you've had these medications before
absolutely
um do you take them regularly or yeah
every day twice a day
do you stop taking them at times no i
don't good for you
no
and depression and
being bipolar and schizophrenia
something that's been
you've been dealing with for a while um
yeah absolutely
yeah i've been dealing with it for a
while
do you feel like the
those
mental conditions
are maybe why you're using the drug
absolutely not
no no not at all
i mean do you feel like using crystal
meth or dope as you call it yeah as i
call it is that is is that exacerbating
your your problems um no not at all and
using it is just it's it's in my life
it's in it's what it's what it's what i
like to do you know what i mean
yeah it hasn't made them better or worse
it's just maintained actually to do now
that i think about it it's maintained me
you know what i mean
i mean but you're trying to raise a
child yeah and trying to raise a child
you get your life together you're 31 so
you're old enough to
be supporting yourself absolutely but
you're running out of jail and
and homeless and
i just wonder if the drug might be
making your situation worse absolutely
not it's made it a whole lot better
really absolutely what does crystal meth
do for you um well what it does is it
allows me to meet people and talk to
them you know what i mean because
without it i wouldn't be able to
i have no reason to talk to them like
you're so introverted yeah i guess so
yes so the crystal meth makes you more
like so i can talk to people meet them
you know strangers especially i wouldn't
meet strangers
if that's the word for i don't know what
you call people you don't know yeah
wow that's interesting
so but your childhood back to that what
was how did you describe your childhood
uh my childhood was a good childhood i
was the only child
so um
i
you know i had my parents had friends
and they'd bring their kids over on the
weekend and we'd play with our doll
house a barbie doll house i had a choice
a lot of choice my mom went through my
toys consistently she never uh
you know uh you know like she went
through them like uh to make sure they
were all intact you know so my stuff was
nice and neat and in order my dad was
around yeah my dad was around yep and no
no crazy of you something like that no
but my st but he's my stepfather my
parents did divorce oh i see yeah
but there was no sexual abuse no not at
all
and the
mental conditions kind of started
showing
it she started showing up around uh i
started showing
i'm sorry they started showing um one
i'm sorry i'm sorry to interrupt you no
just when do those start showing up in
your in your life like at 10
oh early yeah 10 years old
yeah
which one
they first diagnosed me with bipolar if
that was i'm sorry to interrupt you
again bipolar which one is the biggest
problem for you depression no no the
schizophrenia
how how does that manifest itself
because it it allows you not to think
it's like i can't think for my own self
i'm thinking for all kinds of things you
know i mean scattered or something
yeah
and then schizophrenia combined with
crystal meth
oh it's like leveled it's better yeah
absolutely
what does the doctor think of that um
uh you know you can't stop me i guess
he hasn't told me what he thinks about
it
how are you supporting yourself when
you're on the street on gr
the ebt card
who first introduced you to uh crystal
met
my friend virginia
yeah
early yeah
you guys weren't even in high school yet
nope
do you have friends now
uh absolutely you do yes especially the
ones i've met
recently you know what i mean
like on the streets yeah really
and you've been in love before
no never no
[Laughter]
is it because because you're so
introverted that that's no that's not
why no
you just haven't met anyone nope exactly
yeah that happens
so on the medications which you're
taking right now right you've been taken
in jail yes so you're stabilized kind of
yes
but you haven't had crystal meth for a
while no
is that the first thing you're going to
do today yes
wow
so are you looking to get a job or do
anything to stabilize your life or are
you just going to
run in and out of jail again um i'm
gonna um
i'm gonna have to get a job yeah i'm
gonna have to get a job
and on crystal meth that'll be okay yeah
um
yeah that'll be fine that'll be okay
you have any regrets in your life
um
no
nothing yet nope nothing yet
and your family is supportive and they
absolutely understand the
the situation you've got going on with
all these medications yeah i don't know
if they understand but they're
supportive
that's great
tell me what jail how jail affects you
um jail well what's a women's jail like
um i hear about men's jails all the time
or prisons um it's it's the women are
really um pretty you know and and they
really are friendly the staff is really
warm and um
and uh
workers they're they're like they're
real workers you know what i mean
so it's not treacherous like a men's
prison or jail no not at all
not at all are there drugs in the jail
no not that i've come across
what was your favorite memory as a kid
um
[Music]
eating on my my um
my kitchen table
yeah that's nice nope
and you're you're you have a son or
daughter daughter daughter she's how old
enough nine
nine
had have you been consistently
consistently in her life absolutely no
yes
and is the father
is her father
around yes oh he she's staying with him
right yes that's right
so do you have plans for your future
um
um yeah i do have plans it's just to
do um get back on track you know what i
mean and stay and find a
if these don't work better you know
increase then i have to find a stronger
dose these meds are really what i have
to be on too
you know what i'm saying that's my plans
for my future i think there's a lot of
people living on the street that
probably should be taking those
medications that aren't yeah okay and
that's why they're in the situation
they're in okay so you you your
your opinion is that these are helpful
absolutely you need to be consistent
absolutely
how bad do you get if you don't take
them um
i tend it's really bad i'll sit in the
hot sun and not even want it like i also
drink
so i'll i'll sit and i won't even go get
a uh i won't even go look for change or
ask for a dollar to go get a beer if i
don't take these meds i'll just sit
there in the hot sun
which makes no sense to me now that you
know what i'm you know but i do take
them and there hasn't been it's only
been one time that i wasn't taking them
and that's what happened to me and i
almost went to you know where to jail
yeah because you can't just sit there
and and
and you know like you know what i mean
look so unhappy if you're so unhappy
somebody could help you i guess is the
motto you know what i mean are there are
there other people in your family who
have similar mental conditions um
no just you yeah just me
and your only child yes so
veronica what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life um the most important thing i've
learned is that
people will accept anything
and make it everything for them you know
what i mean
people are very accepting
that's the most important thing
all right
veronica thank you so much for sharing
your story you're welcome and i wish you
the best of luck enjoy your
freedom thank you
stay well thank you thank you
you